- [Narrator] Over the past few years,
one Chinese company has thrived
in the online fast fashion industry
reaching a valuation of 66
billion dollars in 2023,
and controlling 40% of the U.S. market.
It's-
- Shein.
- I say Shein.
- It's Shein.
- Shein is known for
$2 T-shirts and $7 pants
with prices even lower
than its competitors.
Shein made its U.S debut in 2015,
and the brand's sales exploded
during the pandemic growing
sixfold in two years.
The company generated an estimated
23 billion dollars in revenue in 2022.
And its filed to go public in the U.S.
- Shein takes fast fashion
to a different level,
and they're on top of every micro trend.
- [Narrator] But there's a larger story
behind Shein's low prices.
A congressional report
found that Shein uses
a tax exemption to cut costs,
and the company released a report
that cited cases of involuntary
labor in its supply chain.
This is the economics of Shein.
Scrolling through Shein's
website can feel endless.
- We offer thousands of new items per day.
- [Narrator] But Shein
only initially produces
100 to 200 units of each new product.
- Shein's designs originate
with Shein designers
and with our Shein X
third-party designers.
- [Narrator] As customers
browse those designs,
Shein has technology
that monitors user engagement activity.
When a customer shows interest in an item
by hovering over it, clicking on it,
or adding it to their
cart, Shein takes note,
then it creates new designs
based on data from popular items.
This way, the retailer can test
how popular an item is with its customers.
If it does well, Shein
starts producing more.
- This differs from traditional retail
where orders can often
be placed in the 10,000
to 100,000 copies of a garment
and can be placed between three
and six months in advance.
- [Narrator] And while it's
fast at creating new designs,
it's also quick to go through them.
A Boston Consulting group report
found that Shein has an inventory
turnover rate of 40 days.
That same report found that Shein
is twice as fast
as other competitor
retailers like H&M and Zara.
- The small batch model is a
matter of controlling the cost
and controlling the inventory wastage
so that they won't have
a large number of clothes
that are sitting unsold in
their warehouses in China
or in the U.S. or anywhere
else in the world.
- [Narrator] The company
calls this an on-demand model,
and to support this on-demand model
and lower prices,
Shein hires thousands of
smaller manufacturers.
It took the journal to film
in one of its third-party
supplier factories in Dongguan.
- Our designers will
identify an item, design it,
prepare a spec for it,
and then they'll put it into
our supplier management system,
which will identify a
contract manufacturer.
That contract manufacturer
will procure the supplies
necessary to produce that garment
from a network of suppliers
that Sheen has approved.
- [Narrator] If a design is popular,
Shein's ordering platform
can automatically place another order
with its platform working in real time.
- They're able to see as
demand for a particular product
is either waxing or
waning in the marketplace
so they can adjust their
operations accordingly.
And this concentration of information
allows our suppliers
to efficiently structure
their own business
to be able to meet
demand at near real time.
- [Narrator] By ordering
in smaller batches.
Shein says it can reduce
the risk of excess unsold inventory.
- It means that we don't
carry excess inventory waste
when we produce garments.
That saves around 30 to
40% in cost of goods sold
on the garments alone.
- [Narrator] But while less
inventory waste in the factory
may lower prices for consumers,
environmental activists say
it might not lead to lower
waste levels overall.
- [Shen Lu] Critics are saying that
because Shein's clothing is so cheap,
people are buying a lot of it.
And because fashion conscious young people
may retire some of their Shein quicker
than other more expensive clothing
that actually may cost inventory wastage
after the consumption happened.
- Oh my goodness, there's so much.
- [Narrator] A 2023 UBS report
found that the average U.S. Shein shopper
reported spending $100 per
month on women's clothing.
That's about 60% more than the
average U.S. female consumer
and critics argue that
there's even more behind
how the brand is able to keep prices low.
- Retailer Shein is in
hot water once again.
- Shein has faced
accusations of worker abuse.
- The brand has recently come under fire.
- Shein's on demand business model
is not the only reason why
its products are so cheap.
It's also benefiting from
cheap labor in China.
- Shein has not been fully transparent
about its supply chains.
In 2022, Shein released the results
of its supplier audits,
but unlike some other retailers,
Shein didn't disclose
who its suppliers were or
where they were located.
The audits reported some incidents
that involve what the company
calls involuntary labor,
but didn't mention exactly how many
or where these incidents occurred.
The Wall Street Journal's calculations
found that these audits
accounted for about 36%
of Shein's contracted manufacturers.
The company said in a statement
to the Wall Street Journal,
"Shein is committed to providing
a safe and fair work environment
for all our suppliers employees.
We pay manufacturing
suppliers competitive rates
so they can pay fair
wages to their workers."
Shein says it's committed
about $70 million
towards improving supplier
factory conditions
and training workers.
Congress is investigating
Shein's labor practices
and whether the company sources cotton
from China's Xinjiang region.
The U.S. government has
accused Chinese authorities
of using forced Muslim Uyghur
labor, which Beijing denies.
- Some U.S. lawmakers have pushed Shein
to be more transparent
about their supply chain.
- [Narrator] In a statement to WSJ,
the company says it has zero
tolerance for forced labor,
does not have contract
manufacturers in Xinjiang
and doesn't source cotton from China.
Fashion Analysts say
Shein hasn't provided evidence
to back up these statements
including a list of its suppliers,
which goes against industry standard.
And in addition to its on-demand model
and low labor costs,
Shein also keeps prices low
by taking advantage of
a U.S. tax exemption,
which allows low-valued packages
to enter the U.S. tariff-free.
Under the de minimis tax rule,
shipments sent to individual
buyers in the U.S.
aren't subject to tariffs if
they're worth less than $800.
According to a report
from the U.S. House of Representatives,
30% of all packages shipped
to the United States each day
under the de minimis rule are
from Shein and its rival Temu.
Between the two companies,
that adds up to millions of packages.
Shein says that it supports reforming
the de minimis exemption.
Meanwhile, the valuation has fallen.
The company's $100
billion valuation in 2022
dropped by a third in a fundraising
round earlier this year,
and Temu, which launched last September,
overtook a larger share of
the U.S. market last June.
Recently, Shein has tried
to improve its image
through social media
amidst environmental and labor criticisms,
but with limited success.
Shein brought a group of influencers
to tour factories in China.
- [Shen Lu] The tour
didn't really help address
a lot of the criticisms that
people have about Shein.
- [Narrator] The company has
also moved its headquarters
from Nanjing China to Singapore.
Shein is also trying to
diversify its supply chain
outside of China.
With this move,
Shein is also adding new
manufacturers in other countries.
Although the majority
of Shein's supply chain
is still in China,
the company promised
to invest $150 million
to train 2000 Brazilian manufacturers
over the next three years.
And Shein has recently
partnered with Forever 21
and acquired roughly one third
of the fashion brand's
operator, Spark Group.
- Shein has in recent months,
been trying to pivot
to a marketplace model,
which allows third-party sellers
to sell products directly to consumers
as Shein expands globally
and is trying to capture more
of market share in the U.S.
and in other countries around the world.
(upbeat music)